Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dansScienceClic,
les ondes électromagnétiques.
Imaginons une particule qui possède unecharge électrique.
De par sa charge,
la particule génère autour d’elle unchamp électrique.
Ce champ électrique est statique.
Il ne varie pas au cours dutemps,
du fait que la charge reste immobile.
Mais imaginons maintenant qu’on accélère
cettecharge, de sorte à la mettre en mouvement.
Au moment de l’accélérer,
la particule vaacquérir une certaine vitesse.
D’après la relativité restreinte,
cette vitesse,que vient d’acquérir la particule,
entraîne l’apparition
d’un champ magnétiqueautour d’elle.
Mais les champs électrique
et magnétique sont intimement liés,
ils sontles deux facettes d’un seul et même objet,
le champ électromagnétique,
et ils vontpar conséquent interagir l’un avec l’autre.
En particulier, le champ magnétique qui vient
d’apparaître, va perturber le champ électrique.
Cette perturbation du champ électrique va
à sontour venir perturber le champ magnétique.
De proche en proche, petit à petit,
les champsélectrique et magnétique vont s’influencer,
et varier l’un après l’autre, perturbationaprès perturbation.
De cette façon, le mouvement qu’on a infligé à la particule,
va se répercuter dans tout l’espace,
petit à petit, se propageant à la vitesse dela lumière
à travers les champs électrique et magnétique.
C’est ce phénomène
qu’onappelle une onde électromagnétique.
En fonction de l’accélération
de la particule qui la génère,
une onde électromagnétique
va être plus ou moinsénergétique.
On peut ainsi classifier les ondes
en plusieurs catégories d’énergie,
en fonctionde la fréquence à laquelle elles oscillent.
On y trouve notamment la lumière visible,
avecles différentes couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel,
mais pas seulement.
Les infrarouges, lesultraviolets, les micro-ondes,
les rayons X, les ondes radio, ou encore les rayons gamma,
toutes ces ondes que l’on ne peut pas voir avec nos yeux,
sont pourtant elles aussi des ondes électromagnétiques.
La grande majorité de ces rayonnements nous est invisible,
mais avec nos technologies actuelles,
il est possible de concevoir des caméras spéciales
et des instruments de mesure desorte à les détecter,
ou à les émettre.
C’est cequi est exploité pour les fours à micro-ondes,
les télécommunications
et autres transmissionsà distance,
mais aussi l’astronomie et les télescopes spatiaux.
Les astronomes observent
l’univers avec différents types d’ondes,
car on peut ainsi s’en faire une image
beaucoup plus large et détaillée,
comparée à ce qu’on peut voir en se
restreignant uniquement à la lumière visible.
Dans la nature, les ondes
électromagnétiques sontprésentes partout.
Dès lors que des particules chargées s’agitent,
changent de vitesse, oude direction,
elles génèrent de telles ondes,
qui vont se propager dans l’univers.
Notamment,tous les objets qui possèdent
une température émettent de tels rayonnements.
Pour comprendre,
il est nécessaire de se plonger à l’échelle microscopique.
Ici, la température d’un objet
correspond à l’agitation des atomes.
Mais les atomes sont composés de deux parties,
un noyau de charge électrique positive,
et un nuage d’électrons de charge négative.
Ens’agitant, les atomes vont faire vibrer leurs nuages électroniques.
Ceux-ci se comportent unpeu comme
s’ils étaient reliés au noyau par un élastique.
En vibrant, toutes ces chargesélectriques sont donc constamment en train d’accélérer et de changer de direction.
Les atomesvont ainsi
émettre des ondes électromagnétiques,
qui sont d’autant plus énergétiques
quela température de l’objet est élevée.
Le corps humain par exemple,
dont la températureest d’environ 37°C,
est en permanence en train
d’émettre des rayonnements infrarouges.
Cesondes ne sont pas visibles par nos yeux,
on ne voit pas les autres humains briller,
maison peut les détecter avec des caméras thermiques.
Une particularité très intéressante
des ondes électromagnétiques
est cequ’on appelle leur polarisation.
Comme on l’a vu précédemment,
les nuagesélectroniques au sein des atomes
se comportent un peu comme
s’ils étaient reliés au noyau parun élastique.
Quand les atomes sont agités,
les nuages électroniques vont vibrer
autourdes noyaux dans toutes les directions,
et les ondes qui sont générées
vont avoir uneforme très chaotique.
On dit que ce type d’onde n’est pas polarisé.
Imaginons qu’on envoie uneonde
de cette forme sur une particule chargée.
Sous son passage, la particule va subir une force
car elle interagit avec les champs électriques
et magnétiques qui composent l’onde.
Elle va alorsse mettre à vibrer
de la même façon que l’onde,
et donc de la même façon
que les atomesqui l’ont générée.
C’est de cette façon par exemple que le Soleil
est en mesure deréchauffer l’atmosphère terrestre
depuis des millions de kilomètres.
Sa chaleur se transmet
depuis sa surface jusqu’à notre atmosphère,
par le biais des ondes électromagnétiques
qui se propagent dans le vide.
Mais dans certaines situations,
il estpossible de faire vibrer les atomes
d’une façon beaucoup plus contrôlée.
Au lieude prendre des trajectoires chaotiques,
les nuages électroniques
vont alorsvibrer de trois façons possibles.
Pour comprendre,
imaginons une bille,posée sur une table,
et qui serait reliée à un clou
à l’aide d’un élastiquetrès tendu.
Imaginons qu’on lance la bille, avec des vitesses différentes.
On observeque sa trajectoire
va le plus souvent former des ellipses,
et quelques fois deslignes droites, ou des cercles parfaits.
Au sein des atomes,
les nuages électroniquessont attirés par les noyaux
de la même façon que la bille est attirée vers le clou.
Ainsi,ils vont eux aussi
pouvoir vibrer de ces trois façons possibles,
et de la sorte générerdes ondes
électromagnétiques très propres,
avec une forme bien régulière et répétitive.
On dit que ces ondes sont polarisées,
avec une polarisation rectiligne, elliptique,ou circulaire.
Les antennes radio par exemple,
font osciller des atomes selon l’axe de l’antenne.
Elles génèrent ainsi des ondes très propres,
qui oscillent de façon régulière,
et avec une polarisation rectiligne.
En ce qui concerne la lumière, sa polarisation
n’est pas directement visible à l'œil nu.
En effet, nos yeux ne sont
sensibles qu’àl’intensité lumineuse,
mais pas à la direction
des champs électriques et magnétiques.
Cela dit, c’est une propriété très importante,
qui va influencer la façon dont la lumière
interagit avec les objets.
Il existe en particulier des filtres qui permettent
d’absorbercertaines polarisations plutôt que d’autres.
On appelle ces filtres des polariseurs.
Ilssont notamment utilisés
pour la technologie du cinéma 3D,
où on peut ainsi projeter deuximages
simultanément, avec deux polarisations différentes,
et concevoir des lunettes avecdes verres polariseurs
qui ne vont faire passer qu’une seule des deux polarisations,
et doncune seule des deux images, pour chaque oeil.
Enfin, les ondes
électromagnétiquesétant des ondes,
elles évoluent dans l’espace et réagissent
avec la matièreselon des phénomènes bien particuliers.
Tout d’abord, comme toutes les ondes,
elless’ajoutent les unes avec les autres.
En particulier, si on superpose deux bosses,
onva obtenir une bosse deux fois plus grande,
alors que si on superpose une
onde avec son exact opposé,
les deux vont parfaitement s’annuler
de sorteà n’avoir plus aucune onde finale.
On appelle ce principe
de superpositiondes ondes, les interférences.
Les interférences des ondes sont notamment
à labase du phénomène de diffraction,
qu’on observe quand une onde
rencontre un petit obstacle,
ouqu’elle passe à travers une fente très fine.
Ensuite, comme on l’a vu précédemment,
lorsqu’elletraverse un milieu transparent composé d’atomes,
l’onde électromagnétique va générer
une force surles nuages électroniques,
de sorte à les mettre en mouvement.
Ces vibrations au sein des atomes vont
elles-mêmes émettre des ondes,
qui se propagent dans toutes les directions,
et qui partagent àpeu près
les mêmes caractéristiques que l’onde initiale.
Ainsi, même si on l’éclaire
selonune certaine direction,
le milieu va produire de la lumière
qui se diffuse dans toutes lesdirections,
c’est ce qu’on appelle la diffusion.
L’atmosphère de la Terre est un très bon
exemplepour illustrer le phénomène de diffusion.
L’atmosphère en elle-même n’a pas vraiment de
couleur, c’est un milieu transparent.
Mais le Soleil envoie constamment des
rayonnementsélectromagnétiques vers notre planète,
et en particulier de la lumière blanche,
qui estcomposée de toutes les couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel.
Au passage de ces ondes,
les atomes quicomposent l’air vont se mettre à vibrer,
et ainsi à diffuser la lumière dans toutes lesdirections.
Mais le phénomène de diffusion est
d’autant plus puissant que l’onde esténergétique.
Les teintes rouges, jaunes, et vertes,
correspondent à des ondes relativementfaibles,
tandis que les teintes bleues
possèdent davantage d’énergie.
Ce sont donc les ondes decouleur bleue
qui vont davantage faire vibrer les électrons,
et donc se diffuser, et c’est pour
cette raison que le ciel nous apparaît bleu.
Pour finir, lorsqu’on envoie une onde
électromagnétique sur un matériau, par exemple de l’eau,
une partie de l’onde
va continuer son chemin dans la matière,
tandis que l’autre partie va
rebondir dans l’autre sens.
On dit que l’onde est réfractée dans unsens,
et réfléchie dans l’autre sens.
D’une part, commençons par
nous pencher surle phénomène de réflexion.
Quand on envoie de la lumière sur un matériau
conducteur,comme le métal à la surface d’un miroir,
certains électrons à la surface ne sont pasliés aux atomes.
C’est ce qui donne au métal sa capacité à conduire l’électricité.
Mais au passagede l’onde lumineuse,
les champs électromagnétiques qui la composent
vont venir mettre en mouvement
ces électrons libres.
De cette façon,
des courants électriques vont apparaître à la surface,
et cescourants reproduisent
parfaitement la forme de l’onde incidente.
Les mouvements de ces électrons
à la surface du métal vont à leur tour générer une onde,
similaire à l’onde incidente,
maisqui se propage des deux côtés de la surface.
En haut, cette onde correspond à l’onderéfléchie,
quand on se regarde dans un miroir, c’est cette onde,
qui est générée par les courants
électriques dans le métal, que l’on va voir.
Et en bas, l’onde générée par lescourants électriques
est parfaitementopposée à l’onde incidente.
Les deux vont doncinterférer,
de sorte à annuler l’onde initiale.
D’autre part, la portion d’onde
qui aréussi à traverser la surface de l’eau,
semble bizarrement se propager
dans une directionlégèrement différente,
et surtout se déplacer plus lentement.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la réfraction.
La réfraction est un phénomène complexe,
qui est dû encore une fois
à la superposition deplusieurs ondes.
Au passage de l’onde incidente,
les atomes et leurs nuages électroniques
vont se mettre à vibrer dans l’eau,
de sorte à émettre des nouvelles ondes
qui vont s’additionner à l’onde de départ.
Mais ces nouvelles ondes sont légèrement
décalées par rapport à l’onde incidente,
et ceci va avoir pour effet de ralentir
lefaisceau lumineux dans sa globalité.
Il est important de comprendre
que la vitesse de lalumière, en soi, n’a pas changé.
Les champs électromagnétiques
réagissent toujours à lamême vitesse,
et chacune des ondes générées par les atomes
se déplace à la vitesse de lalumière.
Mais le faisceau lumineux,
qui prend en compte la somme de toutes les ondes,
ralentitbel et bien, du fait de toutes ces superpositions.
Un faisceau de lumière se propage donc
moinsvite dans certains matériaux, que dans le vide,
et il est possible pour des particules
de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière,
ou plutôt de dépasser la vitesse de propagation
d’un faisceau lumineux au sein d’un matériau.
A la façon du bang qui se produit
lorsqu’unavion dépasse la vitesse du son,
ce phénomène entraîne l’apparition d’un flash de lumière,
c’est ce qu’on appelle l’effet Tcherenkov,
et c’est une méthode utilisée aujourd’hui
parles scientifiques pour détecter les neutrinos.